welcome to this video playing chess I
po11 we are probably always have
problems with L and I am and one this is
a one though I think okay let's see
playing the the English Defence this
tricky opening with be 69 32 mm i
recently experimented with this an IG
form d3s this looks a bit of a bit
passive
okay still I can't play you five that
takes five play d4 or something like
that well after your 5 do I have
something else can I go to g4 or is this
some completely bonkers it doesn't
doesn't take he doesn't advance he takes
the sim at least shouldn't be a problem
d formamide where's he going after
default doesn't really have a good
square
yeah but what about 90 for him native
form
94 bishop dat should be four czechia
wins the house I know he's got 93 which
still is interesting if I go night if
why his goggles Queen a4 check yeah I
bishop dat somewhat tricky move anyway
94 bishop things / should be four check
Knight c3 be takes c3
mmm kingi to I take on c3 isn't this
winning I think this is just I think
this is winning I don't know well there
you calculate all this and then he gives
away chief ride ok I just take the the
be snow white resigns come on ok now but
let's let's have a look at this I hope I
was right here kompis on 000 that's cool
my idea was check night takes and now
take here uh he actually just recaptures
hmm when I was calculating is um let's
say the King moves here I'm threatening
this and see to I was calculating that I
can actually take and then have this
check which is good for me yeah computer
agrees but he can take here and here I
didn't really I didn't really continue
to calculate I wasn't thinking here and
then well let's let's play this me it's
a at least a mess computer wants to go
here and play a three yeah well I've got
got three three minor pieces check yeah
this would have been funny to to to be
played on the board computer gives it as
equal with the perpetual coming but all
this is just a crapshoot in this game I
much prefer black because you've got all
the pieces coming towards the king but
very very tricky here I also had the
simple solution to give the check with a
good game but ok well I divorce just
more interesting ok thanks for watching